I said I was keeping an open mind let's
see how CNN handles the Trump Town Hall
maybe they will hold Trump accountable
maybe it will be produced in a way that
Trump can't steamroll Caitlyn Collins
and tell lies with a sycophant crowd and
everybody's going to cheer and uh you
know it won't just be Caitlyn Collins
meekly every once in a while trying to
fact check but unfortunately that's
basically what it was and we can
simultaneously say
Caitlin Collins offered some token
resistance she did try to do some fact
checking sometimes more successfully
sometimes less successfully in the
context of trump lying uncontrollably
spreading really dangerous corrosive
lies about American democracy in front
of a crowd where when they cheered it
was the absolute worst stuff the worst
of making fun of sexual assault victim e
Gene Carroll uh attacking Caitlin
Collins is nasty when the crowd cheered
or laughed you knew Trump was doing the
absolute worst stuff and so Caitlin
Collins tried but she couldn't even
remotely control Trump in her defense
very few people could and that's where
we have to question what was the reason
for doing this town hall
it's May of the year before the election
there isn't even really a serious
challenge or to Trump yet I know
DeSantis is in the 20s DeSantis isn't
running right now Nikki Haley has no
shot Vivek ramaswami has no shot so why
do a town hall like this in May of 2023
for the ratings it's that simple Chris
slicked taking over CNN and saying this
is what we're going to do Trump ignored
the token fact checks he spoke over
Caitlin Collins the crowd cheer there
was no way to control it when you zoom
out I don't see how America was served
by this event I don't see how voters
were served and the way I'd characterize
it in some total is Caitlin Collins did
the best job she could by herself
on stage in front of a crowd of trump
sycophants but the situation made it an
impossibility it was doomed to fail and
after the break will look at the
reaction from uh some in the media and
some in elected office
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it and you'll get
15 off when you go to boncharge.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below